vamos a ilustrar algunos de los
conceptos que hemos visto sobre el
dinero y sus funciones con una de las
monedas un poco más conocidas a nivel
mundial y que se presta para ilustrarnos
estos conceptos vamos a hablar del dólar
estadounidense y esto nos ayudará a
comprender por qué estos pedazos de
papel tienen valor aunque en el caso del
dólar estadounidense no es papel es un
tipo de algodón pero bueno lo importante
es entender que hace que este objeto
aparentemente inútil y sin valor propio
no sea útil
un ejercicio interesante para estudiar
las monedas en cualquier país es ver su
historia veamos como lucían los primeros
dólares estadounidenses aquí tenemos uno
de los primeros dólares que fueron
impresos y vamos a dar un acercamiento
para ver sus detalles todo está en
inglés pero no importa voy a explicarles
qué significa cada parte aquí dice
certificado de plata
qué significa eso aquí abajo dice que
esto certifica que se ha hecho un
depósito en la tesorería de los estados
unidos de américa y este enunciado
continúa aquí abajo pues nos dice que lo
que se ha depositado en la tesorería es
un dólar de plata pagadero al portador
bajo demanda lo que significa es que
originalmente este dólar representaba y
en teoría podíamos tomar este pedazo de
papel y llevarlo a la tesorería de eeuu
y a cambio recibir una moneda de un
dólar de plata este pedazo de papel
representaba a un dólar de plata esto
nos garantizaba que en la tesorería
existía un dólar de plata que respaldaba
a este papel
y más adelante veremos cómo lucen estas
monedas de plata de manera que a cambio
de este pedazo de papel de un dólar
podían darnos una moneda de plata de un
dólar por lo cual lo que le daba valor a
este pedazo de papel era la garantía de
tener una moneda de plata física
respaldando a este papel de manera que
podíamos intercambiar este billete con
otras personas de la misma forma que lo
haríamos con una moneda de plata ya que
la otra persona al ahora ser el portador
de este billete pues a su vez podría
cambiar este por una moneda de plata si
así lo quisiera y la razón para tener
estos billetes es que era bastante
inconveniente andar cargando con monedas
de oro y plata a todas partes lo que es
verdad especialmente con cantidades
mucho mayores por ejemplo aquí tenemos
un billete de diez mil dólares es un
billete que no se ve con frecuencia
hacemos un acercamiento para ver con
detalle las garantías que respaldaban a
este billete veremos que es bastante
similar pero ahora el respaldo es en oro
en lugar de plata
estos 10.000 dólares en oro se podían
pagar al portador bajo demanda como
autoriza la ley así que esto respalda va
legalmente la idea de que esto podía
intercambiarse por diez mil dólares en
oro de manera que las personas podrían
tratar esto como si en realidad fueran
diez mil dólares en oro sin tener que
estar cargando el equivalente en metal y
qué es lo que nos daban bajo demanda si
queríamos cambiar uno de estos billetes
por plata o por oro pues en ese entonces
otra forma de dinero que se podía usar
en comercio e intercambiar con las
personas como medio de intercambio son
estas monedas pero la diferencia con
estas monedas es que están hechas de
metal valioso estas están hechas de
plata si por alguna razón estas personas
ya no confiarán en el gobierno de eeuu
podrían tomar estas monedas fundir las
usar la plata para otras cosas en otros
países también consideran valiosa de la
plata
así que conserva su valor de la misma
forma tenemos estas monedas de oro que
solían usar las personas
estas son monedas de oro que equivalían
a dos y medio dólares así que esto tiene
en sí mismo su valor ya que suponemos
que las personas valoran el oro y aunque
este pedazo de metal no tuviera este
elegante símbolo del gobierno de los
eeuu de américa
seguiría siendo algo valioso porque es
oro y este dinero como las monedas de
oro o las monedas de plata tienen un
nombre especial se les llama dinero
mercancía y esto significa que el objeto
que estamos usando como dinero lo que
estamos intercambiando tiene valor por
derecho propio aun cuando no fuese
dinero
sería algo valioso esta palabra
mercancía simplemente significa algo
valioso podría no ser solamente oro
sino cosas como comida inmuebles o
ganado son bienes y quizá podrían decir
que el oro y la plata pues tampoco son
valiosos pues son bonitos y útiles para
la joyería e incluso para ciertos
electrónicos la razón por la que las
personas consideran esto como valioso es
porque se usan para intercambio y porque
otras personas lo consideran valioso así
que es algo extraño que estos sean los
ejemplos más relevantes del dinero
mercancía cuando de hecho otras
mercancías como el trigo o las naranjas
nos pueden parecer algo más valioso más
tangibles más valiosos por sí mismo que
estos pedazos de metal pero no importa
esto es mercancía y la otra forma de
dinero que tenemos aquí que es algo que
en teoría podríamos intercambiar en un
banco y el banco nos daría la pieza de
plata o de oro correspondiente al valor
de este dinero a este dinero le llamamos
dinero respaldado por mercancía ya que
su valor está siendo respaldado por el
valor de la mercancía que este dinero
representa otro término que pueden
escuchar es dinero representativo ya que
están representando a otro bien en este
caso oro o plata pero en los primeros
días del dinero hace miles de años se
usaba cierta cantidad de peso de cebada
como moneda por lo que no siempre se ha
usado el oro y la plata como moneda así
que así era el dinero antiguo en eeuu y
este tipo de dinero no sólo se usó en
eeuu sino también en otros países muchos
países tenían dinero respaldado por
mercancía pero en épocas modernas es
común no tener ninguno de estos tipos de
dinero por ejemplo este billete de un
dólar no está respaldado por plata
no se puede llevar al banco y obtener
plata a cambio y a esto se le denomina
dinero fiat y la palabra fiat significa
decreto o declaración de manera que el
gobierno de los eeuu de américa ha
declarado que esto es dinero al hacer
esta declaración pues se presume que se
le otorga valor a este dinero de manera
que se siente un poco más superficial
que el dinero mercancía o el dinero
respaldado por mercancía pero hay un par
de cosas que están respaldando a esto
vamos a hacer un acercamiento para ver
las palabras aquí esta parte dice que
esto es moneda de curso legal el término
en inglés
para todas las deudas públicas y
privadas y en el vídeo pasado hablamos
sobre la idea de moneda de curso legal y
vimos cómo esto da cierto respaldo
siempre y cuando ustedes confíen que el
gobierno va a respaldar sus leyes como
dice que lo hará pero realmente lo que
hace que esto tenga valor es el hecho de
que otras personas confían en esto la
razón por la que valoramos tener un
billete o moneda es porque sabemos que
podemos dárselo a otras personas y éstas
estarán dispuestas a intercambiar por
esto cosas valiosas y finalmente es lo
que hace que los dólares de plata o este
billete de diez mil dólares de oro
tengan valor porque casi nadie llevaba
estos billetes a cambiar al banco por el
metal que le correspondía porque qué
caso tiene esto es tan bueno como el
metal y es mucho más conveniente llevar
estos pedazos de papel que pedazos de
metal pesado así que una vez que esto
fue aceptado en la psicología de la
sociedad y todos se hicieron a la idea
de intercambio
estos pedazos de papel para poder
obtener cosas de valor no costó mucho
trabajo tener realmente pedazos de papel
que no estaban respaldados por alguna
mercancía siempre y cuando todas las
personas confieran en esto y esto sigue
sirviendo a las funciones del dinero que
vimos en los vídeos pasados es un medio
de intercambio también es un depósito de
valor este papel no va a degradar se y
es algo que podemos guardar y también es
una unidad de cuenta nos sirve para
asignar un número a varios bienes allí
afuera pero es algo que fue declarado no
es algo valioso en sí mismo y es una
diferencia importante el hecho de que
este dinero fiat realmente es un dinero
de fe se tiene la fe en que las personas
van a considerar esto valioso y de hecho
esto también se cumple para el oro y la
plata ya que se tiene fe de que las
personas considerarán estos metales
valiosos y por eso los aceptarán lo
mismo va para el oro y de hecho aunque
muchas culturas consideran valioso al
oro
para otras culturas no lo es tanto y
quizás ven este metal y digan bueno no
entiendo por qué tanto alboroto con esto
así que la idea de que usamos el dinero
basándonos en la confianza o en la fe de
que otras personas lo van a considerar
valioso también no es para nada absurda
siempre y cuando sirva a estas tres
funciones básicas del dinero podremos
tener una sociedad funcional esperando
no tener cosas como la hiperinflación
que haga que esto ya no cumpla con las
funciones del dinero nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo